Come close, I've got a secret for you...
...closer,
...closer...
Ok, ready?
This is 'What If,'
and here's what would happen if
everyone on Earth lived in one city.
To date, the greatest population
density ever recorded
was in Hong Kong's
Kowloon Walled City.
Before forced evictions
took place in the early 1990s,
there were 33,000 people
sharing this space,
which is about the same area
as three football fields.
And that's equivalent to 1.2 million
people per square kilometer.
You can understand why
this walled city had to go.
But even if that's an extreme example,
our world is home to
some pretty dense cities.
Manila is a city with roughly
43,000 people per square kilometer.
While the population of Manhattan is
about 26,000 per square kilometer.
And while they're not ideal
circumstances for claustrophobics,
most people can make it work.
It could...
but comfort would
vary depending on the density.
Let's start with a fun city that
has a pretty low population density.
New Orleans is roughly
784 people per square kilometer.
If you were to scale New Orleans to
accommodate everyone in the world,
you'd get a city the size of
the continental United States.
But if you were to do the same thing to
a high population density city like Manila,
which, as we said, has a
population density of 43,000,
then everyone in the world would have to fit
into a city the size of the country of Uruguay.
It's hard to speculate on what life would be like
if everyone in the world lived in a city this size.
In some ways, it might be more sustainable.
We'd save money on huge infrastructure
projects like long highways and bridges.
Travel and transport costs would go down,
since all the materials we'd need
would be going to the same place;
and that might make
basic human necessities
like food and medicine more accessible.
Not to mention, having everything
from work to home
to the supermarket and the
shopping mall within walking distance,
or accessible by public transit, would
reduce our environmental impact.
In fact, people in cities
use half as much energy
as people who don't – because they
live in smaller spaces.
But when we think about urban living today,
it's impossible to ignore the cost of rent.
With space at such a premium,
And what kind of quality of life
could low-earners expect?
In Hong Kong, for example,
an incredibly dense city
with the most expensive
housing market in the world,
a 40 square meter (430 sq. ft.)
apartment costs about 700,000 USD.
In some places, that kind of
money could buy you a castle.
But with the world crammed into one city,
your living quarters might look more like this.
The kind of geo-city we're envisioning
raises a lot of social questions.
People tend to move to cities
for better opportunities,
but, would there be
enough to go around?
Would the high concentration
of wealth inequality
that's often overlooked in today's world
breed more crime? Or even revolution?
Would there still be wars?
Or would proximity to one another help
us to understand each other a little better,
and realize that we're
not so different after all?
A truly global city is hard to imagine
because distance and
diverse perspectives
have bred different approaches
to urban planning.
Is there a one-size fits all
approach to cities?
How can we make urban life
sustainable and accommodating to all?
Luckily, the world will never
live in just one city,
but these are questions we
need to start taking seriously.
Because urban density is on the rise,
and like it or not,
we're just gonna have to get
more comfortable with each other.
Do you know someone
who's claustrophobic?
Show them this video, and
stay tuned for more 'What If.'